c'est le deuxième anniversaire du décès
de cédric joue via triste anniversaire
ce père de famille de 42 ans mort des
suites d'une asphyxie consécutive à une
fracture du larynx
les faits se sont produits lors d'une
interpellation policière sur laquelle
pèsent de lourds soupçons de violences
disproportionnées
le 30 janvier 2020 cédric jovial est
interpellé par quatre policiers sur le
quai branly où je me trouve parce qu'il
le suspectait de téléphoner des
automobilistes film alors la scène
cédric joue via tourne autour de
l'équipage voulant filmer avec son
téléphone
le livreur termine au sol sous
l'impulsion des policiers très
rapidement il perd connaissance et
décède à l'hôpital deux jours plus tard
outre la tragédie de la mort d'un homme
pour un motif aussi futile un téléphone
ou une plaque d'immatriculation salle
c'est l'attitude des policiers qui est
rapidement de mises en cause selon leurs
dires c'est vrai que je souviens c'est
montrer irrespectueux agressif ou
menaçant alors qu'il aurait été mis au
sol et menotté il aurait continué à
insulter les policiers puis son visage
serait devenu bleu il est ensuite
question de malaise cardiaque qui se
serait produit spontanément les
policiers ni tout clé d'étranglement il
parle d'un simple maintien de tête la
femme de cédric souvient est appelée au
commissariat on lui explique alors que
son mari est tombé tout seul et a fait
un arrêt cardiaque bizarre les avocats
de la famille font alors un appel à
témoins et comme un ultime pied de nez
du livreur l'enregistrement audio de
l'interpellation a été intégralement
enregistrés par le micro du casque de
cédric souvient la version policière ils
volent en éclat et l' enquête de l'igpn
publié en juin 2020 dévoile de
nombreuses dissimulation tout d'abord
elle décrit un échange correct entre les
policiers cédric souviens bien loin du
ton menaçant et des insultes décrite par
les fonctionnaires de police tout au
plus le livreur les at il traité de
clown ou de guignol est en fait il est
poussé physiquement à plusieurs reprises
par l'un des agents qui ne supportaient
pas qu'il le film avec son téléphone
alors quid des insultes au sol a légué
par la police hier en réalité on en est
loin cédric joue via qui suffoque
demande juste d'arrêter écrit plusieurs
fois qu'ils étouffent juste après les
faits un collègue de la brigade
anticriminalité arrivent sur les lieux
qui s'avère être le compagnon de la
policière de l'équipage c'est lui qui
transmettra des infos erronées ou
parcellaire au commissariat et la
préfecture faisant état d'un arrêt
cardiaque et niant tout étranglement un
seul rapport sera ensuite rédigé pour
les quatre policiers alors que chacun
aurait dû apporter sa version lors des
auditions des policiers celui qui a
pratiqué la clé d'étranglement avoue que
son geste n'était pas volontaire qu'il
n'a jamais eu la sensation d'être
anglais pire alors que les policiers
avaient prétendu être intervenus
immédiatement après la perte de
connaissance de l'homme le rapport de
l'igpn démontre qu'il faudra attendre
trois longues minutes avant que le
premier massage cardiaque ne soient
prodigués cette tragique histoire qui
remet tristement à la une la technique
controversée de la clé d'étranglement
conduire à la publication d'une tribune
de personnalités de gauche appelant à
son interdiction de fait cette pratique
a bien été supprimés en juin 2020 par
christophe castaner alors ministre de
l'intérieur
désormais trois autres technique
interdisant toute pression continue au
niveau du larynx ont été mises en place
le 16 juillet trois des policiers sont
mises en examen pour homicide
involontaire
mais pour le reste beauvau semble bien
faire bloc derrière les accusés car les
policiers ont bien été mis en examen
certes mais ils n'ont même pas été
suspendu à la surprise générale le
ministère de l'intérieur a refusé cette
requête des avocats de la famille de
cédric joue via les fonctionnaires de
police ont le soutien de toute leur
chaîne hiérarchique
selon les termes de leur avocat
les proches de cédric joue via en deuil
auront eux aussi besoin de soutien la
route est longue pour que la famille du
livreur obtiennent justice